[Music]
with the total of 24 characters
Dragonball Fighters has a sizable roster
that will satisfy fans needs for some
classic Dragon Ball moments but we could
always use more bandai namco has
announced eight DLC characters coming in
the future and while they haven't
officially announced who they are yet
after all rumors are still rumors
we can still speculate on who we would
want to see fighting alongside Vegeta
Gohan and the rest of the game so here
are our picks for the Dragon Ball
characters that we want to see in the
game
[Music]
Dragonball Fighters roster is full of
Dragonball Z and super characters but it
could use more from the original
Dragonball launch is one of the more
memorable ones one minute she's a blue
haired homemaker and the next she's an
aggressive blonde
sounds like a Super Saiyan all it takes
is one sneeze which would actually make
for a pretty cool dramatic intro and
while it might seem odd to see a
character whose arsenal mainly consists
of machine guns and rocket launchers it
definitely won't be the first for Bandai
Namco
[Music]
every fighting game needs at least one
character that switches things up in an
interesting way as a galactic patrolman
sworn to protect universe 7 Jocko has
has fair share of bizarre adventures
throughout the galaxy occasionally
crossing paths with the Z fighters he
may be a bit timid but this space cop is
also a pretty skilled fighter with a
number of high-tech gadgets at his
disposal armed with a ray gun jet boots
bombs and other tools
Jaco could be a welcome change of pace
from the other characters on fighter's
roster
[Music]
Goku's childhood mentor may have since
been eclipsed by his former pupils but
as Dragon Ball super proves the wily
turtle hermit can still hold his own in
the fight thanks to his deep bag of
tricks what Master Roshi lacks in
strength compared to the other fighters
he more than makes up for an experience
and should he make an appearance in
Dragon Ball fighters we'll hopefully see
some of his special techniques like
Thunder shock surprise or the evil
containment wave
[Music]
as the reigning World Martial Arts
champion mr. Sutton is known far and
wide for his superhuman skill and
strength well at least to his fans while
his powers aren't on the same level as
Goku or Vegeta he can still hold his own
against a couple of phone books
hey actually be a pretty cool super and
unlike most of the cast and fighters he
can't fly or use energy attacks which
might regulate him to hand-to-hand
combat mostly and could really make for
an interesting play style
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Goku's older brother Raddatz was the
first major villain introduced in Dragon
Ball Z arriving to earth ahead of his
fellow sans nappa and Vegeta and handily
defeating Goku in battle while he only
appeared in the series for a very brief
time he was still an important character
in the Saiyan saga if only because he
revealed the truth behind Goku's origins
and set the stage for a much bigger
battle Raddatz may pale in comparison to
the other scenes right now but he was a
memorable villain who deserves a spot on
the Dragon Ball fighters roster
[Music]
like their sons Goten and Trunks Goku
and Vegeta had fused together on several
occasions and depending on what method
they use they become either Vegeta or
Gogeta both are extraordinarily powerful
fighters worthy of a spot on the
Dragonball fighters roster but as Vegeta
played a major role in both Dragonball Z
and Dragon Ball super la Gogeta appeared
in a film in the non-canonical Dragon
Ball GT he seems to be the more likely
of the two fused warriors to make the
cut
even as a small boy Goku has shown to
have incredible strength and fighting
skills so naturally his younger
iteration could be a great addition to
Dragonball Fighters along with his
signature Kamehameha kid Goku knows a
variety of different techniques that his
older self rarely uses anymore like the
solar flare and afterimage techniques
which would actually make his moveset
unique from his adult counterpart he can
also wield his childhood weapon the
power pole to help compensate for his
shorter reach
[Applause]
[Music]
universe sixes collie flaw has the honor
of being the first female Super Saiyan
she's unique in that she concentrates
her key in her back to transform rather
than relying on intense emotions and she
achieved Super Saiyan one and two very
quickly in Dragon Ball super Kali flaw
could appear in Dragonball fighters in
tandem with her protégé kale kind of
like Android 18 and 17 plus she promised
to give Goku a proper beating someday
what better place than in an Arc System
Works fighter so those are the
characters that we are hoping to see in
Dragonball fighters there are so many
more to choose from and who knows just
how many bandai namco will eventually
add into the game so let us know in the
comments who you'd like to see have
added in as DLC and don't forget to
check out GameSpot calm for more
Dragonball Fighters news features and
our full review of the game my name is
Joey
and thanks for watching